whatever I do I think would just be like
Asian man gets bitten by a homeless
you already know
uh we're gonna see um a short film oh
it's kind of going around right now
uh and uh
no oh this one oh I heard about this
what a [__] [__] dude I love how
there's music
[Music]
dude him Crossing his feet doing it uh
such a dick that's been so me going
around for a minute huh that's been
going around viral like right around now
yeah yeah I mean it went through its
rounds already like he got his uh
statement out and then now they arrested
him in shade so context for everybody
who doesn't know this is a San Francisco
Art Gallery owner who is caught on video
spraying a homeless woman with a hose
um he was arrested this past Wednesday
for this act and the D.A called his
actions completely unacceptable I mean
it's already been raining so the
homeless people have been like in a
flood and then he's hosing her down
yeah you can't do this that's too much
is it a double standard what if it was a
dude that's the thing would be okay and
like the gallery owner was a chick no
it's like a dude on dude I don't think
the gender matters I think is the action
that is pretty funny I think they were
on this if they weren't sitting but they
were posing a threat and he was using
the hose as like don't [__] bite me
then it's like oh okay that's different
but then it just seems like he's kicking
down because she's already sitting down
on the ground and then he's just he got
that posture too right like there's such
a dick when he's doing it well they did
also report like headlines for that [__]
straight up said white man sprays black
homeless woman also which was black oh
my they want to lean into that I know
it's like come on like I um I did read
some other things
the the homeless lady was I guess like
harassing or there's just been some
backstory they have an ongoing thing and
then they're like yeah so we asked her
to move all this stuff and then things
wouldn't so then instead of like being
able to physically move her that was his
stupid solution and he said that like
through the year or whatever that he's
let her sleep on and stoop he said all
these things about being supportive to
her but there's no evidence of that yeah
yeah we don't know there's no video
nobody was recording that yeah my
viewing experience was when I first saw
that I was oh that's [__] up but then
I started thinking about uh when I was
living back in Glendora and there's that
one guy that would like play all the
construction sites being on everyone's
door and was like pretty much a nuisance
yeah and
um I've been at like my neighbor's house
because he he lived there for a year
before I moved in and there was one time
me and him he was like just showing me
like oh this is like what I'm doing to
my backyard and mid talking
this guy just Sprints like outside of
his living room and goes outside and he
goes what the [__] did I tell you about
coming back here because he was a police
officer and then you see that guy oh
[__] and he's [__] just he books it
right because he looks about to get his
ass beat and he comes back and goes that
[__] and I was oh dude I've seen
that guy around so now if I put myself
in that mindset and if you have a guy
that is constantly either [__] in
front of you ruining her business uh and
it's one of those like well you have no
right to move me I could be I'm like I
could see how someone that really got
annoyed over six months or whatever
could just snap yeah well [__] it then
if you don't I'm gonna maybe he
threatened I don't know maybe he was
like if you don't move I'ma spray you
and she'll go ahead and do it and then I
don't know
yeah so for me I'm kind of like split
where I'm like right from the get-go
it's cold as [__] there's another human
being why the [__] would you do that and
then also it's one of those things where
you call the cops and the cops will show
up and go
can't do anything right that's what he
said happened 20 he said there's like a
record 29 calls damn that they they
didn't do nothing it's [__] up but
it's one of those things where it's like
I don't know what the right answer is
like obviously not spraying her in the
face is not this top of the list like
don't do that yeah but it's like spray
the tree and let it come down
yo or just record yourself already like
I watched the sidewalk every week so I'm
just gonna spray around you yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like this thing yeah
I don't know I'm just gonna spray around
unlike another option probably maybe
water balloons no that's not fun but it
doesn't even solve the problem because
all it does is now she's in someone
else's front front of the store like
she's still yeah it doesn't solve the
issue right and then so like the main
issue solves his issue yeah but now
she's in someone else's front yeah and
he's gonna spray her you just gave me a
sprain her like that bro I mean that's
the main thing is like that's why I was
like oh you can't do it you just can't
do that bro like we've all had
situations at least if you own a
business you have dealt with this like
there's just no way around it in LA but
as bad as you might want to do that you
still can't do that like it doesn't
matter there was this homeless lady that
was staying outside the gym and she was
out there every single day and she was
like this Native American woman and she
was really sweet and then we'd just be
like we're not gonna tell you to [__]
leave and we're gonna be like what's up
we would say hi to her and then she
eventually just stopped coming around
like we were just kick it with her we
would like just be cordial with her you
know but she wasn't probably doing she
wasn't doing like anything crazy like
until they're like breaking the law yeah
like she wasn't being a wild lady but
then like I'm sure that of course that
would have changed the whole dynamic but
it's like dude like just stick dude this
guy's standing like this it's the
posture and everything the smugness bro
it's so small and he's it's an art
gallery like oh God like you're such an
[__] yeah he should have just put us
he should have put a Super Soaker in her
hand so it looks like there's a two-way
fight
this changes the whole oh don't get me
got like a raincoat on and everything
yeah no it's just they're having a water
fight it's just so obvious that that's
just not allowed like it doesn't matter
what how you feel about the situation a
better move is like okay say if she was
like pooping outside of his house and
like outside oh that sucks and being
wild he should take a bucket outside and
pop a squat and poop right next to it in
front of her that's the better move that
is Art I [__] like that
yeah yeah and then maybe they hang out
maybe that's the best [__] buddy cop
movie ever seen I get that it's his way
of revolting and to show that the system
is failing you can't but you're just
playing the wrong role in that one of
the bossest ways I've seen people handle
uh like homeless problem is uh there was
like a get-together at Geo's mom's house
right next door is this empty Warehouse
that's full of like homeless [__]
Bandits that was born in their [__]
Panda yes the only wires and scraps
bike and just throw the bike and just
dive in and then you see him like come
out with [__] just like the gym
cereals and then they're like riding
they're riding away right and then I was
like I was like [__] I don't even know
how to like go about this like they're
about to have like 30 kids over and then
Jill's uh family has like this gangster
ass looking cholo dude he has like a
[__] 67 money could you just have a
dude like that every family got one so
he rolls up he rolls up I'm like oh [__]
I think he'd be good to talk to them
because I don't know what to say
whatever I do I think I'm gonna just be
like Asian man [__] gets bitten by
home
you already know your headline on next
shark
Asian YouTuber or whatever
Dynamite vest comes up yeah
I better stay out of this this fool
rolls up in his [__] Armani Carlo
he's like bald [__] he's all big and
[__] he comes out and he goes hey
everyone come over here five bucks to
everybody to everyone that cleans up
this Alleyway and bounces and everyone
just starts cleaning [__] to
start sweeping and [__]
and I was like damn this [__]
Denzel Washington this way out of this
yeah dude and he just passed out pretty
much 20 bucks they all just did whatever
and they just all bounced and I was like
that was smooth but that only works on
Tweakers though because like I've seen
those guys and I think they're not like
gone like this lady like if they're like
you might be gone go on like that need
they just need mental help like she's
been talking to herself like she might
bite somebody like they're not really
there just like look I'll give you 20
bucks if the tree that you chill at is
just that tree over there for the month
but she might be like I'll give you a
hundred bucks and you let you dance with
me you're like [__] the counter is too
good
so [__] bad situation happened in
real life I would just be like let's
dance
give me a hundred Let's Dance
a lot of the you got 100 bucks a lot of
the homeless people like that I see or
in Waikiki a lot of them are just
mentally like they need a lot of support
they're not panhandling they're like
talking Imaginary Friends they're just
they need mental health they're just
gone so they're not they're not out
there like
they're just sometimes like scaring
tourists or whatever right but I felt so
bad because there's so many security
guards and their most of their job is to
deal with like the the homeless
population that come into the street and
so in in one area
um where I have my like office at I walk
down I saw the security guard and then
in the morning this this homeless dude
was yelling at all the people there
so he had to like talk to him and all
that and I heard him like he was getting
berated by the dude and he was like
trying to fight him and all this and all
he had to do was just like be the only
guy to like try to calm this dude down
yeah he's not logical he's just nuts
right and so at least his attention's on
the security guard the security guards
like this tall like Hawaiian dude and
then the the guy that's like homeless I
don't know what he is but he was out
here calling him Holly which is like
white guy or whatever right or like
Foreigner and so I'm like what is he
looking at because this guy is obviously
a Hawaiian guy like and then so he's
like you how he's coming here and do all
this stuff and then he's all bro he's
like I was I'm from here like he's
trying to talk sense to him right none
of that and I'm just doesn't work [__]
so I go I go into the uh uh you know
work whatever come back four hours later
he's still standing there yelling at him
but now he's like tired so he's sitting
while he's like yelling at him and no
one's there to help no cops nothing and
I'm like dude you have to deal with this
[__] he goes dude it's like every week
every week there's like somebody that's
just off their [__] rails and then
like I just have to stand here and watch
and talk to him yeah and I'm like that
is [__] rough man and then so all of
these places with with homeless like
situations like this I think one is like
they need like
like a um like some type of Social
Service like that we used to have like a
mental institution I don't know if
that's the right word to call it but
like you know like we used to have that
but I think it was in the 70s or
something
and it just released them all that's
kind of tight in terms of like
especially the security guard uh like
expects or knows that's his job like and
it's just like oh yeah because it's me I
just got to talk to them like at the end
of the day even though it's like crazy
ass homeless people they just want
somebody to talk to you sometimes you
know what I mean so if as long as it
doesn't get dangerous if you're just
kind of like oh yeah I just gotta talk
to them until they're done talking
that's a tough gig yeah